la mère de bina se rend dans l'église
avec le gardien des clés
elle ramène sur l'autel ce calice du
xviiie siècle et de bougeoirs ils
avaient été dérobés ici le 20 mars 2019
ce n'est pas le premier vol dont
l'église est victime mais c'est la
première fois que les objets de culte
sont restitués on est très content nos
églises sont absolument déshabillé de
tout objet qui peut être emporté
donc on en a eues vous savez beaucoup
beaucoup d on ne pensait pas du tout les
retrouver la mère à récupérer ces pièces
plus tôt dans la journée à la
gendarmerie de blois et elle était loin
d'être la seule
ça fait plaisir au moins ils retournent
d'où il vient et puis voilà pensez bien
cette commune se sont vus restituer 18
objets religieux la plupart du 19e
siècle
il avait été dérobé entre mars et avril
derniers c'est la brigade de quimperlé
qui procède à cette restitution
car c'est elle qui a mené l enquête
après la découverte sur une brocante
d'objets volés en bretagne nous avons
pris attache avec ses procureurs et aux
fils de l'enquète nous avons identifié
l'auteur du des méfaits et il s'avère
que cet auteur rapidement on s'est rendu
compte que l'intéressé avait volé dans
multiples départements
le voleur un sdf sarthois sévices est
dans toute la france depuis fin 2010 8
et il revendait ses objets à des
antiquaires je pense que leurs favoris
c'est quand même de l'argent les métaux
se négocie assez facilement donc il ya
de la demande à l'étranger sans problème
on sait que certaines pièces partent à
l'étranger très rapidement c'est pas
forcément des commandes
c'est simplement des opportunités même
s'il ne s'agit pas d'un trafic organisé
le nombre de vols d'objets liturgiques
est en hausse depuis 2017
l'enquêté toujours en cours et il reste
quarante pièces à identifier sur les 114
saisie